Let's continue using our equation solving skills to tackle some other problems.
This time we're going to try motion problems. The primary concept we're dealing
with, with motion problems is distance equals rate times time. For any object
that moves at a constant rate. We can find the distance that it travels by
multiplying its rate by its time. The time is how long the object is traveling
at that given rate. So, let's say a car is traveling at 60 miles per hour and
it traveled for 2 hours. Well, that means in 1 hour it goes 60 miles, so in 2
hours it goes double that, which is 120 miles. This formula should make sense,
and the units down here should also make sense. We know if we multiply miles
per hour times the number of hour, our hours will cancel leaving us with just
miles. So if we know that distance equals rate times time. What equations could
we write for the rate and for the time? In other words, I want you to solve
this equation for r and write the expression here. And then solve this equation
for t, and write that expression here.